MICHAEL BASILYAN: Hey, guys.
Thank you very much for coming.
Very exciting to see
so many people here
turning out for Batch Compute.
So we're going to talk
about large scale and batch
computing on GCE.
I'm going to introduce
the cast of characters
for the next hour.
I'm Michael Basilyan.
I'm a product manager in GCE.
I work on batch scenarios.
I also work on our
preemptable VM product,
for those of you that
are familiar with it.
I make it my day job
to worry about what
happens on GCE with
respect to Batch Compute,
help customers who are
using it, how we can make
their lives better, and so on.
In the second half, you'll
hear from Burt Holzman, from--
he's an assistant division
head for scientific computing
at Fermi National Laboratory.
And he's going to
talk-- he's going
to walk you guys through
some very exciting work
that they did.
Some really fundamental science,
on Google Compute Engine.
How they did it,
what the story is,
and including some
the science behind it.
So, let's go quickly
through the agenda.
So, we're going to start off
with an introduction which
is really just one slide about
what batch computing is, just
because--
almost just because you have to.
And then we're going to talk
about preemptable VMs, which
is a product near
and dear to my heart
and it's very interesting.
Then we're going to talk about
storage options for batch.
So obviously, batch computing
doesn't happen in a vacuum.
You're not just using a CPU,
you're actually storing data
and you need to put
that data somewhere.
And when you look at the variety
of options we have on GCP,
there's a lot of them.
And so I'm going to help give
you guys a initial direction
in which you can go in when
designing your architectures.
And then we're going to talk
about architectures for batch.
And obviously we're not
going to talk about just
general architectures
for batch in a vacuum,
we're going to talk about
them in the context of GCP.
Especially if you're migrating
a batch system to GCP,
you will get some idea of
what are different tools
and how to put them together
to make things happen.
And of course, then
everybody's favorite topic,
saving money, and actually
scaling up, and making sure
that while you're
scaling up the cost
doesn't scale proportionately
with the size of your compute.
And then in the second
half, we'll hear from Bert.
And of course there will
be time for Q&A at the end.
Great.
All right, so what
is batch computing?
I think we're all kind
of familiar with what
batch computing is,
but really the way
we define it is, for the purpose
of this talk and in general,
it's really any
kind of computation
that's done offline.
This is as opposed to, let's
say, online computation
like a website or
an application,
where there's a
user playing with it
and they expect
immediate responses.
Batch computing is,
I have a binary.
I have some amount
of data, I say,
hey, computers, take this
binary, run out on this data,
give me the results and
I'll come back to it later.
Some interesting
examples are, of course,
rendering, as in the case
of movies or other images.
Transcoding, either videos
or audio or images from one
format to another,
maybe reshaping it etc.
Finance and accounting,
engineering and scientific
simulations, of course,
classic data analysis
is, of course, just
another form of batch.
And there's lots of
different modalities.
There's lots of different
ways people do it.
There's embarrassingly parallel,
or maybe high throughput
computing is sometimes called.
There's always tightly coupled
high performance computing
or MPI.
Those are all terms used for it.
OK, let's talk a little
bit about Preemptible VMs.
So what is a Preemptible VM?
Well, let's start
with the good parts.
First of all, they're
incredibly cheap.
They're up to 80% cheaper than
a regular GCE virtual machine.
They cost around
$0.01 per core hour.
They're very easy to use.
In fact, if you guys are
familiar with our GCloud tool,
it's Gcloud, Compute, Instances,
Create, then dash dash
preemptible, and just hit Enter.
To create a regular VM, you
just remove the dash dash
preemptible, and you've
got a regular VM.
Many of our customers are
actually using them for VL.
This isn't some sort
of like excess compute
that's just sitting on the
side and that we're sort
of giving away as fire prices.
We have clusters, and
you'll hear from Bert,
we have clusters that
are over 10,000 cores.
But some things to keep in mind.
One, same great VM, same great
options, same great networking,
same images et cetera.
Almost every feature that's
available for regular VMs
are available for preemptibles.
But, we can and do preempt them.
That's why they're
called preemptibles,
it's right there in the name.
You get what you pay for.
We give you-- if we do
decide to preempt your VM,
we'll give you 30
seconds worth of notice.
And then we will send
a shutdown signal.
You can use a shutdown
script, as usual,
to handle the shutdown event,
and then back up your data
or do what you need, but you
get 30 seconds of notice.
The other caveat is we only
give you 24 hours of up time.
If your VM is not
preempted in the 24 hours,
then we just shut
it down for you.
And of course, there's no
SLAs or guarantees because,
when we can take the thing
away, what kind of SLAs
can we give you?
All right, so usually when
I tell this to people,
they're like, OK, that's
just sounds crazy, right?
Like, you're going to
give me a virtual machine.
I'm going to pay you
relatively little for it,
but you're going to just
take it away whenever.
Like, what can I
possibly do with it?
Well, the idea is that
you're not doing something
with one virtual machine.
You probably have a few of them.
And you have some workload.
And the best place where
these are applicable
is when you have a workload that
has a lot of individual units
that are independent and small
relative to the workload.
So let's take the example
of media transcoding.
Let's say you have a
few million images that
might be coming
from a satellite,
or being uploaded
to some website,
or something,
something, something.
And then what you want to do is,
you want take all these images
and you want to transcode
them into some other format.
Maybe you want to
rescale them, maybe you
want to greyscale
them, whatever it is.
What you'll do is, you'll put
these images in some storage
location.
And we'll talk
about your options
for that in a little bit.
You will have a master node that
is definitely not preemptable.
You'll use a master node
that as a standard VM,
because you generally don't want
your master node going away.
I haven't seen
any scenario where
anybody's used the preemptible
for the master node yet.
And then you'll spin up a whole
bunch of preemptible machines.
You will take images out of that
storage location one at a time.
You'll assign them to
the preemptible machines.
And they'll start actually
running the code that you
have on those machines.
And they will actually
do the computation
for you, the transcoding
of the images.
Of course, if one of your
machines does get preempted--
and they will get preempted--
you haven't really
lost anything.
All you've lost is the work
to transcode that one image.
All you will do is, your master
node will realize, oh, hey,
we lost this machine.
This image never got transcoded.
So I'm just going
to queue it back up
and assign it to a
different preemptible,
or maybe to another
[INAUDIBLE] machine and so on.
So that's a pretty
common use case.
There's obviously others.
There's satellite
image analysis.
There's rendering, like I
mentioned, data analysis,
genomics, financial analysis.
And there are some
things you can
type in your favorite
search engine
to get some articles
and blog posts.
Cool.
All right, so let's actually
talk about data and storage.
As you guys know, on GCP we
have a bewildering amount
of storage options for you.
In fact, what's actually
missing from the slide
is the fact that we
now have Spanner today.
And today I'm going to
talk about two primarily.
I'm going to talk about
our object storage options
and block storage options.
That's persistent disk
and Google Cloud Storage.
Of course, you will
still use things
like relational databases or
NoSQL databases in your batch
scenarios.
For example, if you're
transcoding images,
again, you might want to say
for this image the target
resolution is x, the
target color depth is y.
There's some metadata
associated with that image
that you want stored
and persisted.
Or perhaps you have
different priorities
for the jobs et cetera.
Cool, so let's talk
about block storage.
Just to be a little bit
clearer, block storage--
think about block storage as
the regular hard drive attached
to your PC.
And we have three
primary options.
We have local SSD,
persistent disk--
and we have two flavors
of persistent disk,
SSD persistent disk and
hard drive persistent disk.
Let's start on the far
left with local SSD.
Local SSD is our fastest option.
So if you have a batch job
that's constantly referencing
files, or it's working
with a specific file
over and over and
over again, or it just
really needs low latency, you're
going to go with local SSD.
Like the name
implies, it's actually
physically attached to
the VM, to the hardware
that your VM is running on.
That's why it's local.
On the flip side,
it's ephemeral,
which means that once
your VM is terminated,
your local SSD just goes away.
It's really good for, like
I said, scratch space,
when you're actually working
with the data locally
and you need it to be hot.
Scientific workloads, especially
if you're using something
like GPU instances and
you just really want
to chew through data quickly.
It has great IOS performance.
Of course, it is the priciest
of the three options.
And you can get up to
three terabytes of it.
Moving to the middle column,
you have persistent disk SSD.
And after that, you have
persistent disk hard drive.
Unlike local SSD,
persistent disks
are, like the name
implies, persistent.
As you can see, we're very
clear with our naming.
Preemptible VMs are
preemptible, persistent disks
are persistent.
You get what you pay for.
If you need a persistent
disk that's fast,
you'll go with persistent SSD.
It's a little more pricey than
persistent disk hard drive,
but you get great
IOPS performance.
Both of these use 64--
up to 64 terabytes of space.
Everything supports encryptions
and persistent disks
also support snapshotting.
All right, so those-- that's
disk and block storage.
And then we have, of course,
Google Cloud Storage,
which offers object
storage in the cloud.
And we have four
offerings that I'm not
going to go into great depth
on because I don't really--
I recommend you guys go
to the Cloud Storage talk.
If you missed it, I think
it was actually earlier,
then I recommend you guys
check it out, record it online
or just check out our website.
But suffice it to say
that we have four options.
Coldline is the
sort of lowest SLA,
and the assumption
is that you're
accessing data on a rare
occasion when you need it.
So this is like for
archival storage.
And then we have multi
regional offerings
that have very high SLAs,
and they are georedundant,
so you can access your data
from a number of Google Cloud
regions around the world.
But how is this different
than persistent disk?
So, latency is higher.
On the flip side, you
can store a lot of data.
It just scales to exabytes,
whereas persistent disk,
as I mentioned before,
scales to 64 terabytes.
Unlike persistent disk,
it's available from anywhere
in the world.
You can use the REST
interface over HTTP,
just to request
the files you need.
Persistent disk has to
be attached to GCE VM.
Obviously, you can
expose it from there,
but inherently it's
attached to a GCE VM.
It's higher latency,
like I mentioned,
and of course this
isn't blocks storage
so you can't append to a file,
you can't read specific blocks,
you can just insert, overwrite,
read entire files at a time.
It offers versioning,
and of course is cheaper.
So what I'm hoping that you
guys get out of this is,
there is a continuum of
storage options that you have.
On the one extreme, you
have Coldline, and then
the other extreme,
you have local SSD.
And what you probably want to
do is, you want to pick notches
along that continuum
and say, hey
for my perform--
for my application,
when I'm actually
computing, I need
to be in, perhaps, a local SSD,
or perhaps persistent disk SSD.
And then when maybe I'm
not actually using my data,
or for the data I'm not
using, or using very rarely,
I'll put into Cloud
Storage or maybe I'll
put it into Coldline, and so on.
Let's talk about actual
batch architectures.
So these are samples of
what we've seen customers
building on Google Cloud.
This is a very basic
starter batch architecture.
Over here, you have our
Google Cloud Storage buckets.
One of them stores
the input data.
So if, again, we're going
back to the running story
through this talk,
is image transcoding.
If you have a bunch of images,
you might put your input images
into the input bucket.
Over here, you'll have
some analyst, or some--
maybe it's not a
human being, maybe
it's a machine that's creating
the images and putting them in.
And it's putting them
into the input bucket.
You'll have a head node
that is definitely not
running a preemptible VM.
And it's running some software
like HTCondor or Slurm,
or maybe custom
scripts that you wrote.
And it's spinning
up virtual machines
to go out and talk to-- to read
data from the input buckets,
do the actual computation, the
transcoding or the analysis,
whatever it is that
you want to do.
And then it actually
writes the output data
to the output bucket.
So let's say you've been
doing that for a while,
and things are going well.
And then you realize, all
right, well, this is--
I'm sort of waiting
for these files
to come down from
Google Cloud Storage,
and it's taking some time.
I want something that's a
little faster, or a little lower
latency.
What you would probably
do in that case is,
you would take the existing
start up batch architecture,
and you would add to it a
bunch of persistent disks.
So you create a
parallel file system
with some compute nodes and
some persistent disks that
allow you to
basically, effectively
cache the data from Google Cloud
Storage closer to the actual
compute instances for the
moment when you're actually
doing the computation.
And of course, you
can use a variety
of options, like NFS, or
[INAUDIBLE], or OrangeFS
and so on.
Moving on from there, at
some point you'll probably
realize, like, oh
wait, my workload
is like embarrassingly parallel.
And if I lose work, if I lose a
machine, that's perfectly fine.
Why am I not saving 80%
by using preemptible VMs?
And so what you'll
probably do is,
you'll create two
pools of workers.
One of them will be
running preemptible VMs,
and the other one will
be running regular nodes.
It's generally advisable
that you guys don't just
run 100% preemptibles.
It's kind of tempting,
that's 80% off, I get it.
But depending on your
business need and how much
progress you need
to make, you need
to make a call about
what the split is.
I've seen people do it 60-40,
50-50, 40-60, 30-70, and so on.
The thing, of course,
is the preemptible
VMs are preemptible.
We can take them away, and
sometimes we have a need
to take away a lot of them.
And so you want to be guaranteed
that your jobs don't crawl
to a halt and your progress
doesn't crawl to a halt.
And so it's a good idea to,
depending on your needs,
to have some number
of standard VMs.
And beyond that, you might go
out and grow your application
even more.
So in this example, we're adding
auto scaling and health checks.
And I'll talk a little bit
about how that works on GCE.
And this lets you
basically say, hey,
if there's something
going on in my queue,
if there's nothing
in there because it's
middle of the night or
maybe it's a long weekend
and all the analysts went
home and nobody's submitting
anything, just turn off all the
machines because why should I
be paying for it?
Health checks basically say,
hey, if one of my machines
is funky or it's not
responding, just kill the thing
and start it over again.
Or if it got preempted,
create a new one.
Of course, we have the
file system as before.
And we're still using
Google Cloud Storage
for the ultimate backup.
You might have added
alerting and monitoring
with Stackdriver.
Maybe all of this is being
computed at an output somewhere
and then you actually want
to visualize it, or give
your analysts an opportunity
to do some interactive analysis
after the computation.
And of course, you might
add up a backup node.
So let's walk through a concrete
example, where you're actually
doing satellite image analysis.
So, at the very top, you
have your image source.
And what that image
source does is,
it takes images of
the Earth or whatever
it is, and pushes it to the
ingest node which is just a VM.
Takes the data, does some
preliminary analysis on it.
Let's say, for example,
puts it into Cloud Storage,
and then writes some
metadata about that image
into Cloud Datastore.
And it also notifies
the head node that hey,
we have something in the queue.
The head node then goes, does
some intelligent and brief
analysis of the data,
puts it in the queue,
and tells the compute
nodes to go, hey,
you can actually go and
start working on this thing.
The compute nodes, of course,
can also take into account,
we have the Landsat data
on Google Cloud Storage,
which is free satellite data.
They take this data,
put it together,
and then they actually
write the output
through to the computation,
and then write the output data
to Google Cloud Storage.
And then your analysts
can come back,
and then they can actually use
things like BigQuery or Cloud
Datalab to analyze the results.
One thing that I
like to tell people,
when I talk about building
batch systems in Cloud,
is if you've ever built
one of these things
before, you're probably used
to working in this mode.
You have an on premise cluster
of maybe some thousands
of cores.
And all your cores are
pretty much the same thing.
And they are one size fits
all, because you need them
for everybody in
your organization.
And you build a single queue.
And everybody in
your organization
starts using that queue.
Maybe they get
different priorities,
or you have some way of
trading off time, et cetera.
But generally what happens
is that queue gets longer
and longer and longer,
and people get angrier
and angrier and angrier.
I've been in that situation.
I've been at the
end of that queue.
In the cloud, you don't
actually have to build that way.
First of all, you don't have to
buy one size fits all machines.
You can actually do that
with one of your clusters,
but then you might realize
that a whole bunch of people
in your organization,
they actually need GPUs.
So in the old world, you
would probably go out
and buy some GPU machines.
With us, you can
probably rent them--
you can rent them by the minute.
You might realize that a
whole bunch of other people,
they need high CPU
machines, which are
machines that have more CPU--
a higher CPU to memory ratio.
And yet somebody else
needs higher mem machines--
high mem machines that have
more memory than they do--
a higher memory to CPU ratio
than a standard machine.
And so what you
can actually do is
spin up clusters for each of
them, and give each of them
their own queue.
So they're not really competing
with each other for time,
they're competing
with themselves.
And they can choose to make
priorities and tradeoffs
as they need.
And then you control how
much they spend, essentially,
by controlling the
size of the cluster.
In the old world, you
used to have queues that
would just get infinitely long.
In the cloud, you're going to
have lower queue times, which
leads to people actually
being able to iterate faster.
And that usually, hopefully,
has meaningful business results
to you guys, aside from
just people who are happier
and there's less anger,
and less infighting.
And then, each
virtual cluster has
nodes that actually
fit the workload
that that customer, that
internal customer of yours
actually needs.
Rather than just
buying one size fits
all hardware which
leads, of course,
less wasted resources
and less costs.
And of course, when somebody
doesn't need those GPU
machines, you can scale
them down and just
turn the whole thing off.
Or somebody doesn't need
that high mem 32 cluster,
you can just turn of
the cluster entirely.
And because we
bill by the minute,
this makes perfect sense.
There's no reason why you
should be paying for machines
that are sitting cold.
And in the event that
somebody pushes a change
to one of your clusters
and breaks the thing
because it was a
bad configuration
or something, that's just
their cluster that's broken,
not the entire--
not everybody in
the world together.
All right, let's talk about
some best practices on Cloud.
How do you save money?
How do you scale?
And how do you
simplify your life?
Let's talk about
saving money first.
So, as I mentioned
a couple times,
to use preemptible
VMs if you can.
It makes sense.
They're 80% off, you mix
them with your regular VMs,
and you make good
progress that way.
Use custom machine types.
Custom machine
types is something
that I think was actually
mentioned by Urs in his talk
earlier in the keynote.
Essentially,
basically, it lets you
do what you see up in that
upper left corner over there--
excuse me, upper right corner--
where you can actually select
how many cores and how many RAM
you want in a single machine.
You don't have to buy
machines as power of two--
powers of 2.
If you need 14 cores,
or you need 12 cores,
you can actually just set
the sliders to 14 cores
and set the corresponding
memory slider to what you need.
And that lets you fit the
actual machine to the job,
not try to fit the
job onto the machine.
Another cool feature
that we have is instance
write sensing
recommendations, and that's
what you see over here.
You see those little yellow
light bulbs, I guess?
That's basically where
we look at the machine
and go, like, hey, this thing
is being under utilized.
You have a very large
machine, but you're
using very little actual--
you're not using all 14
cores that you selected.
So maybe you just turn it
down and save some money.
So this is just a very brief
overview of all your options.
For those of you who chose to
come here, thank you very much.
At this moment,
right now, there's
a parallel session going
on, "Want to Save money?
Saving money on Compute Engine."
So please find the recording of
it afterwards and check it out
if you want more details
on all the various options
that we have.
All right, now, simplifying your
life and making you happier.
Obviously, Google Compute Engine
is infrastructure as a service.
We provide raw VMs
and networking,
but we also provide some managed
infrastructure services to make
your life a little bit easier.
So for instance, auto scaling.
You don't actually have to
build your own auto scaler.
We allow you to define
groups of instances.
And then apply one of
our existing auto scalers
technologies to it, so that we
actually do the scaling for you
based on the rules
that you specify.
Auto healing?
Similar idea.
You define what it means
for an app to be healthy.
We take a look at it,
and if it's not healthy,
we kill it and
start it over again
based on the instance group.
But this, by the
way, is actually
very useful with
preemptible VMs,
because a machine that's
preempted is not healthy.
And if you have a
managed instance
group of preemptible
VMs, and you
say I want this group to stay
at 100 nodes, and one of them
gets preempted, this
thing will automatically
detect and excrete a new one.
And of course,
there's also rolling
updates and other goodness.
And also going on
at the same time
is a talk on managed
instance groups,
so if you guys are interested,
please do check out that video.
This is, I believe
my last slide,
scaling on Compute Engine.
This is also sort of
in spirit of do not--
or, as much as you can, try
to avoid building this stuff
yourself.
It gets complicated pretty fast.
We have a great solution,
which is essentially
a tutorial on our website called
HTCondor scaling on Google
Cloud with HTCondor.
Basically, search for
HTCondor on Google
Cloud, and you will find a
tutorial and a solution that
teaches you how to
use HTCondor which
is a batch management, open
source application that
lets you build batch solutions
on Google Cloud relatively
straightforward.
And it takes advantage of
preemptible VMs as well.
All right, that's
what I have, and I'm
going to turn it over to Bert
to talk about the goodness done
at Fermilab.
BURT HOLZMAN:
Thank you, Michael.
Everybody can hear me OK?
OK, so I'll talk about how
we provisioned 160,000 cores
with what we call HEP cloud.
HEP is jargon for
High Energy Physics.
And actually, before we
even get into physics,
I should mention--
I have to do the legal
boiler plate here.
So, I work for a
government lab, so I'm not
giving any specific endorsement
to Google even though I'm
at a Google conference.
I can't endorse Cloud products.
I can't endorse clothing
lines at Nordstrom's.
You get the idea.
OK, so, we're trying to answer--
oh, hold on.
You're not reading this
in Morgan Freeman's voice.
We're trying to answer basic
questions about the universe.
So what's the universe made of?
How did it form, and basically
what's the past, present,
and future of the universe?
And the physics of
high energy physics--
the field of high
energy physics, this
is what we're aiming to answer.
So, you know, everything--
everything on this
planet is, you see it.
It's actually here in
this periodic table.
You all had high school
chemistry, I hope.
And you can see
the blue line that
covers what things are made
of out to the atomic level.
But atoms are also
made of things,
and we'll dive down deeper
into what those are made of.
And so, this periodic table
was invented in, actually,
the 19th century.
And this is the periodic
table for the present term.
Quarks, leptons, these are
things that we're doing.
These are things we're
investigating in high energy
physics.
And actually ordinary
matter, the quarks,
the up and down quark
there, and the glueon,
and the electron, that's all
your ordinary matter here too.
And in the center is the
Higgs boson, which I hope you
all heard about a
couple of years ago.
And I'll come back and
discuss that in a bit.
Fermilab, so, what is Fermilab?
We are the United
States' premier lab
for studying this field
of high energy physics.
It always looks like this, even
though we're 40 miles outside
of Chicago.
Right?
And we do completely
unclassified research.
The site's open to the public.
We're the only national
lab that I believe
has zero classified research.
There's my office.
Not the whole building, but
somewhere on the ninth floor.
[AUDIO OUT] Fermilab,
what do we have?
So we have a decent size
facility on premises.
We've got almost 50,000 cores.
We've got a tape capacity
of 100 petabytes.
We've got 35 petabytes of disk.
And we have pretty good
network connectivity
of a multiple of 100 gigabit.
So we have pretty good
resources on site.
And we're also-- I also
work for the government,
so we know how to--
and I work for science, so we
do this as cheaply as we can.
And probably pay people
as cheaply as we can,
unfortunately.
So, I should mention, we're also
the largest computing facility
outside of Geneva--
outside of CERN in Geneva
for high energy physics.
And to do high energy
physics, to probe
these extremely
small scales, you
need extremely big machines.
This is the Large
Hadron Collider
in Geneva, Switzerland.
The ring is about
17 miles around.
And to give you an
idea, if it was here,
if this is centered
here, it almost
stretches out to the Presidio.
And so, it's a big machine.
And I'm going to talk about
one of the experiments.
These are underground.
There's a couple of
interaction points.
I'm going to be talking about
CMS, so one of the experiments
at the Large Hadron Collider.
This is CMS.
That's not me, but
to give you a sense
of scale of the experiment.
You know, these are big.
It's a big ring.
It's forming extremely tiny
things, and so it's strange,
but you need something
extremely big to detect that.
And also, the CMS experiment--
this is the CMS experiment.
It stands for Compact
Muon Solenoid.
I know, compact seems
strange in this context.
What happens?
So, we have protons colliding
14 million times per second,
and this is essentially
a really large camera
that takes pictures.
And we keep-- at about a
kilohertz, so 1,000 times
per second, we keep this data.
And all measurements of a
proton-proton collision, we
call it an event.
So it's a little
different from an event
I heard about earlier, where we
talk about publishing to queues
and so on.
These are events.
They have [INAUDIBLE] content.
And this is a very
complicated beast,
so we need simulations to
understand what we're doing.
And so we have simulations
that go from a stage
where we're basically rolling
the dice and doing random--
simulating events with
Monte Carlo simulation,
through simulating the passage
of particles through matter
and how they radiate, and
how our detector responds,
and in the end, reconstructing
physics quantities.
Not only is the detector
complicated, quantum physics
is in our way, too.
So we can't control our
initial conditions precisely.
And we're only really
sampling a part of the space.
And so we need to use these
probabilistic techniques
to sample these spaces.
And when we analyze this,
we compare our simulation
and extract physics results.
Let me see if I can get
the movie going here,
so you can see a--
this will distract
you while I talk.
So, here's a plot
of the Higgs boson.
Well, it's not the
Higgs boson yet.
What you see is, the black
dots are data filling in.
The blue is a simulation
of the standard model.
That's everything
except the Higgs
boson in that new periodic
table I showed you.
And the red curve
corresponds to a new theory,
in this case it's
the Higgs boson.
And what you see,
as it fills in,
is you can see the Higgs
boson start to emerge.
Not just in our simulation, but
you can also see in the data,
and the error bars
will get smaller
as more and more data
gets accumulated.
So, these simulations are
critical of particle physics.
And we're statistics driven.
We need a lot of them.
We need a huge amount of data.
Oh, I have to move
this back over.
So the scale of
simulations we need.
We're simulating on the order
of billions and billions--
I sound like Carl Sagan--
we're simulating a lot
of collisions per year.
These experiments at the Large
Hadron Collider are needed.
And workflows are--
I'm going to use a
different term than Michael,
they're not
embarrassingly parallel.
They're pleasingly parallel.
We have the benefit of having
these really weakly coupled
things, we can run in batch
and do it efficiently.
So every event that we
simulate, every collision
can be done separately on
its own core in parallel.
And so we need a lot
of compute to do this.
At Fermilab, not everything
is devoted to CMS.
There's 70 data centers
throughout the world.
We've been doing
this-- we've been doing
this computing in this field
since the dawn of computing,
really, and driven
it for a long time.
So we've been doing
this particular--
the LHC turned on less
than a decade ago.
And so we have 70 data
centers throughout the world.
These are universities,
these are national labs,
these are international
laboratories, CERN and labs
all throughout the world.
The tale of the
tape here, there's
about 150,000 cores worldwide
available to this experiment.
75 petabytes of spinning
disk, 100 petabytes
of use tape space.
And we have strong networks
connecting all the sites,
not just at Fermilab, so we can
transfer data back and forth.
We move about five
petabytes back and forth
across all the sites every week.
And across the Atlantic, we
also have 340 gigabits a second.
That's one of the things
we exercised early on.
Make sure we get the data
from Geneva to Fermilab
as quickly as we could.
That's not enough.
That's a lot of compute,
but it's not enough
and I'll show you why.
You are here.
We're in the middle
of run two, where
we've got about 158 petabytes
of data for the experiment.
But we have an upgrade coming
in the next five to 10 years,
where we need estimate or
1,920 exabytes of data.
That's a-- petabytes is big.
This is ridiculously huge.
So we're going to need a lot of
compute to chew through that.
We need to do it
cheaply, because we're--
well, we work for
the government,
and we're trying to get every
bang for our buck that we can
without raising your taxes.
The other interesting thing
for us as a field is that,
when I was asked
about this, five, 10--
five years ago about Cloud
computing, the costs were--
the costs were just too
high, because like I said,
we buy cheap.
We bid, we do things
on a shoestring.
But the cost has come down.
Here is just a plot of
the costs over time,
and they're monotonically
decreasing to the point
where this becomes attractive
for us to use commercial cloud.
So, a challenge.
So we got a--
through a wonderful coincidence
of ex-Fermi people working
at Google and the right people
being in the right pipeline
at the wrong time--
at the wrong time?
At the right time.
Well, we attempted--
so we asked ourselves,
can we double the reach of
this experiment's compute?
Let's do a live demo,
because, you know, why not?
And we'll do it during
Supercomputing, which is
a conference back in November.
Four days, 12 hours a day while
the exhibit floor is open.
And let's do it by expanding
Fermilab using something called
HEP Cloud, to 160,000 cores.
And let's do it so the
application doesn't really
notice.
So what's HEP Cloud?
And I didn't name this.
This is named by the head
of the Office of Science.
But the idea is, it's basically
a portal for our researchers,
where we decide when--
we decide where we're
going to send their workflows.
Whether we're going to
keep them in-house on-prem.
Whether we're to send them
to the grid, to Google Cloud,
to the other cloud up north that
I probably shouldn't mention,
to our supercomputing partners.
We have facilities at
Argonne Lab, Oak Ridge lab,
at Berkeley, at NERSC.
And so we started
a pilot project
to explore our
capabilities, collaborating
with industry and academia.
And the goal is to move--
well, I was given
the guideline, you
should get this into
production in fiscal year 18.
And so the last day of fiscal
year 18 is September 30th.
So I'm going to get it
in by September 30, 2018.
So we're in the R&D phase.
And the architecture--
I don't have a pointer,
so I'm not going to go through
this in tremendous detail.
But on the left of
the dashed line,
we have users
submitting workflows.
That comes into our facility,
and we have a decision engine.
And the decision
engine decides when
we're going to provision based
on workflow characteristics,
based on the pricing, what
the preemptibles are going for
compared to what it
cost us on-prem, what's
available on the
grid, and so on.
And then we either
send it on-prem,
or we have a provisioner
that goes out and gets
all these different
classes of resources,
depending on what makes sense.
And in terms of
the implementation,
how do we do this?
We have a technology was
called the glideinWMS.
Talked about HTCondor a
little bit in the last call.
We use Condor for two things.
We use it to
provision resources.
We go ahead and send in a pilot.
We have-- and it's a whole
completely different talk
why pilot based workflow
management is a good idea.
And we don't have
time for it here.
But essentially, we launch
pilots on the workflows.
It goes in and pulls workflows--
jobs out of the queue, and it
helps validate environment.
It manages the fact these
resources may look different.
And to the users, it can
look like a common pool.
Even at the facility, it'll
And we use Condor
to accomplish this.
All right, so let's
look a little closer
at the architecture
of what we're
doing inside a single zone.
So we have a provisioner talking
to the Google Cloud APIs.
And then we go ahead and that
launches our worker nodes.
We did everything
with preemptively VMs,
because they're priced right for
us, and there's no critical--
we have enough default
tolerance built in.
If something gets preempted,
we just resubmit the job.
There's no magic state we have
to keep with these things,
because every collision
is independent.
We use-- and I'll talk about
the details of this in a bit--
it calls back to our head node
for our overlay batch system.
It sent data back out to
Fermilab to the object store.
We ran our input data
from Google Cloud Storage,
and we also had a--
we also need to get the
application software
to Google in a way that the
end user doesn't notice.
And so we used some web caches
to provide the application
software as well as job
by job calibration data,
caching later in front
of our off site DB.
We didn't just use one zone.
If we're going to
scale that high,
it's advisable to
do more for preempt.
So we covered four
zones in central-1.
You can see the
architecture overall,
and we were reading everything
from a regional bucket
from our input data
displayed in the middle.
OK, so to break apart
some of the pieces here.
So, HTCondor, this is a
batch system, but also
our provisioner.
It speaks Cloud API.
It's initially written-- it's
written by the University
of Wisconsin Madison team.
It's been around
for a long time.
And that's where
Google helped us out.
They contributed to this
open source project.
They added support for this
to speak preemptible VMs,
and service accounts.
And actually, they fixed
a critical bug which
we found the Friday
before we were going
to get the demo on Monday,
to address scaling, where we
couldn't get beyond--
we couldn't get anywhere
close to where we needed to be.
How do we provide the
software to the application?
This is maybe a field
specific technology,
but essentially we have
something called CERN VMFS.
It's named after CERN, the
laboratory in Switzerland where
it was developed.
It's basically a web CDN,
the distributor application
software.
And the idea being that we
have terabytes of software
sitting out there on a disk--
on disks.
We go ahead and just cache
the bits that we need.
It's very efficient.
We need-- and it also, a
lot, gives us the flexibility
instead of sending a single
application into the cloud,
we can have many, many different
versions provided to our end
users, doing the--
sending the
scientific workflows.
And they don't know
about any of this.
This is completely
transparent to the user.
And so we had a managed instance
group, doing squid web caching.
If there's anything
that we know,
cloud providers are terrific
at, and Google's terrific at,
its web, right?
So, it's an internal facing
cache using the IOBs.
And we set it to auto scale,
probably conservatively when
the rates went above of
nine megabytes per second.
And I could give you some
war stories as I go on,
nothing's perfect.
So we had an issue.
These are squid's.
And there's health checks
built in, where they go ahead
and they try to get a file
out of your web server.
That's great for
standard web servers.
It's awful for squids,
because squids are proxies.
When you do a get
on a squid, it's
getting not slash
blah, blah, blah,
but it's getting HTTP and so on.
And the health checks only took
something with a leading slash.
So unfortunately, squid
has some internal URIs,
so that was our solution, or
our hack to go pull those in.
So, if you try to do
this, this will help you.
We pre-stage our
input data to GCS.
So we have an exper--
like I said, we've been
doing distributed computing
for a long time
with a lot of data.
So there's a lot of
field specific technology
that we use.
We have experiment specific
data placement services, which
schedules transfers, places
data sets, and so on.
Just this year the technologies
we're using have speak--
are starting to speak the
right cloud languages.
In particular, they speak--
at the moment, they speak S3,
and so we're able to
use the S3 compatibility
modes to transfer data in.
And we're able to
do it at 10 gigabit.
And the only reason we're
limited by 10 gigabit
is, our object
store, I could not
do third party transfers without
upgrading some bits of it.
And we needed to get
half a petabyte in,
and we had enough time to do it.
So I just let it completely
redline the nick at 10 gigabit,
and we let it go.
And we access these data
using a GCS fuse on startup.
So we access over fuse mounts.
Look like, slash
whatever, whatever,
to the application,
which was great.
And it performed very well.
And along the way,
not just to make sure
the input was working,
but the output looked
like we were going to need more
than 10 gigabit at the scale
we're talking about.
So thanks to Google, and also
our energy sciences network,
the pairing was
upgraded to 100 gigabit
temporarily for
our work, and then
ironically, it was
actually scheduled
to get upgraded a
couple of months later.
So it's 100 gigabit now.
We also converted-- we
had a regional bucket
for Cloud Storage.
We converted that
overnight to save costs.
As we want to realize
that we were fine,
we had enough capacity
in a single region.
Overnight, half a
petabyte was converted,
and it cost us 30% less.
So, right, there's
big question, right?
I talked all this, gave
you all the architecture.
Question is, how do we do?
We do great!
So, this is the
cores from Google.
This is a plot from
our own dashboards.
They're running at CERN.
And the different
colors you see here,
everything else-- everything
that's not purple,
are different sites.
The red is-- the red,
which is, let's see.
I don't have a pointer,
but the red that's on top,
that's Fermilab.
And everything else,
this is everything
we run all over the
world during this time.
And what you see is, we
doubled the computing capacity
for the experiment.
300,000 cores contributing to
science, to high energy physics
during this time.
And here's a plot
from our dashboards.
We're ingesting
this into Grafana.
And the money plot--
I have other plots at
160,000, but there's
one I took a screenshot of.
The money plot is the one
all the way in the middle.
The pie chart, the
yellow is everything
that we have all
over the world, all
these 70 data centers running,
in teraflops per second--
in teraflops.
And the green is what
we're getting from GCE.
So we were able
to hit our target.
And I should say, we
were able to do this in--
we got the go ahead to
do this three and 1/2
weeks before the conference,
before the Supercomputing.
So we were able to do it in
record time, thanks also--
thanks to Fermilab, and
also a great team at Google.
All right, so what are
some lessons we learned?
Michael talked about the
custom machine types.
We started out with a
standard machine type.
That's more than we needed.
We trimmed it down and it
was extremely easy to do so.
And there was a
20% cost savings.
I mentioned the code that
Google helped us fix.
We had a bug in our-- there
was a bug in the code.
It's been there
ever since Condor
put in support for
GCE, which has probably
been three, four, five years.
It ignored the AP pagination
API, which, it really shows up
in funny ways because you get
an alphabetized list of VMs that
were getting deleted out from
under us, because our state,
we had no idea
what our state was.
Google provided the patch.
And then, here's a fun
one, as we were expanding
capacity in the
zone, in the region,
we went from 4k to 16k IPs.
There should be a
carriage return there,
but it's a simple API command,
Gcloud, Compute Network
Subnets, Expand IP
range, and so on.
That's great, except maybe you
see the problem in that red 20
right there in the firewall?
Yeah, 20 is 4k--
20 bits is 4k, so
we ran into that.
We fixed it, but
when you go to scale,
these are sorts of
things you discover.
We would have never
discovered this pagination bug
if we had kept it 10,000
cores or something small.
All right, so here are some
of the numbers, the tale
of the tape so to speak.
We ran about six-- almost six
and 1/2 million hours of wall
time on these resources.
We had five and 1/2
for completed jobs.
We submitted more than 730,000
of these simulation jobs.
And each job is more
than one collision.
It's a whole host of them.
Only 47 didn't complete,
because we have fault tolerance
with our batch, we have fault
tolerance with the application
that feeds the batch.
And once we got out of
the infant mortality
of the first day
of the demo, when
we found some of these issues
like that firewall issue
was day one, where
we hurriedly, where
we spent a lot of time
hacking at laptops to get
to the bottom of that.
The good put, in other
words, which is--
it was at 94%.
In other words, 6% of
the cycles that we had
were wasted in results
we didn't get back.
94% of our compute
came back to us
even though we were using
exclusively preemptible VMs.
So we had a terrific
result. That's
better than a lot
of our grid sites,
which are not
necessarily dependable.
Well, it depends which
university and lab
are going to.
It's a host of sites.
But that's better than a lot
of our grid computing sites.
I'd be fired if it was better
than Fermilab probably,
but-- so, we do--
well, it depends on what
the jobs we're doing, too.
In terms of the cost, so,
if you were the cost--
this is what it cost us
during Supercomputing.
The main cost was,
not surprisingly,
the cost to compute for the VMs.
It cost us about $8.5k
for network egress.
You pay for every byte you
get out of the network.
We optimized our workflow, so
that didn't bite us too much.
There are other workflows
that will cost more.
The disk that's
attached to the VMs
that we needed
for our workflows.
And then the storage, that
half a petabyte that we stored,
cost about $3,500.
We generate 200
million physics events.
81 terabytes of data
for the experiment.
And in terms of the cost--
and these costs have a lot
of caveats built in, so--
it ended up costing us
about $0.016 per core hour.
On premises, our costs are
about a little less than $0.01
cent per core hour, but that
makes a bunch of assumptions.
Number one, that
we're 100% utilized,
and since I work
for Fermilab I wont
show any plots demonstrating
anything different.
It also-- keep in mind I
work, as I've said many times,
I work for the government.
And Fermilab being this high
energy physics frontier,
we have a collider at Fermilab.
It's a big deal.
And we get power for
cheap, because it's a lot--
believe me, it may
have cost you a lot
to run power to your
datacenter, but running
a proton-proton collider
is quite a lot of power.
So we get a good
rate on our power.
So we did this for CMS, for
this experiment I talked about,
the Large Hadron Collider.
We had some credits left over.
We had some impetus
to see what we
could do after Supercomputing.
So how quickly could
we on-board a new user?
Somebody that hasn't
done anything with GCE,
the CMS was part of this run up.
So there's an
experiment called Mu2e.
I won't go into the
physics in any detail,
but the basic idea is trying to
measure the rare decay of muons
to electrons which has
never been observed.
And so it would be
a complete change
to the standard model
of particle physics
and be really interesting.
The experiment's
getting designed now,
so it's in the design stage
of trying to figure out
where to put all of these bits?
And I want to talk
about the technical bits
of what these things are, but
where do you put the detectors
and optimize them?
So that's where
we're simulating.
Different placement,
different geometry, how big
should things be
for this detector?
So, how quickly do
we get them on board?
Less than a day.
They were ready for--
now, this is an
experiment that knew
how to do grid computing,
distributed computing.
But we had all the
tools in place.
They were prepared--
and it took us
less than a day
after Supercomputing
to get them up on GCE.
And what you see here is,
the green is Google Cloud,
and the yellow is
what we're running
for them on-prem at Fermi lab.
So, that's a terrific
result, I think,
and it shows that
our field actually,
having being prepared for
distributed computing,
understands what they need--
understand some
of the things they
need to do to be able to
bring stuff into the cloud.
All right, so what
are we doing next?
Like I said, we're moving to
[INAUDIBLE] in September 2018.
We have this decision engine
component, which is, I think,
really interesting.
The heart of it, it's
also extremely difficult.
And I don't need to get
anything optimal in there,
but that's in R&D.
Our super-- the
Department of Energy,
and again this is your
tax dollars at work,
but we have supercomputers,
HPC facilities.
And these are becoming
much more friendly for data
intensive workflows.
And so, we're provisioning
cycles already at Berkeley,
at NERSC, on Edison and Cory,
and we're expanding this.
There's additional
commercial cloud providers.
And I talked about Google.
We've done something
similar with Amazon.
Next, everybody next on--
since I work for
the government, I
have to put things out to bid.
And we spread things as--
we spread the manure over
as many fields as we
can get to, right?
And then there's non-pleasingly
parallel problems.
So, you know, deep learning.
There are-- there's a
lot of compute involved
with doing these
simulations, and doing
the data reconstruction,
the reconstruction we
do on our data.
But we have other
interesting problems
that may lend themselves
well to deep learning.
We have thousands of tons
of liquid argon detectors,
where we're looked
looking for 3-D tracks.
And when you start looking at
what you need to do with this,
it looks an awful lot like image
classification in 3-D problems.
And so the field is
actually starting
to re-embrace deep learning.
There is-- the
field embraced what
it is called neural networks.
The field got involved, but
we didn't have the compute.
I think we probably had
enough data in the field,
but we didn't have the
compute to really make
a sea change in how
we did our analyses,
and new architectures.
All right, so I just
wanted to thank--
this isn't just my work.
It's a work of cast of many.
So we have a great team at
Fermilab that did the work.
The HTCondor and
glideinWMS projects.
Open Science Grid, I didn't
talk much about this except
in the concept of grid,
but a lot of the stuff
that sits underneath,
the software packaging,
the tooling, the CERN VMFS,
the stuff that gets packaged.
When things land on
our worker nodes,
they have all the tools we need
from the Open Science Grid.
It's a collaborative project
between the National Science
Foundation and the
Department of Energy.
The Energy Sciences
Network, none
of this-- you can't do any of
this without networking data
intensive science.
Our team at Google, Michael,
Karan, Solomon, Sam, Paul--
the Pauls, and Doug Strain.
And, you know, I again--
I work for the government.
I can't buy stuff directly
from Google, either.
Your terms and conditions
are things I can't agree to.
So you need to go
through resellers
that take care of that for us.
And I can't advertise
for commercial products,
but I will advertise
for the laboratory.
So it's our 50th
anniversary at Fermilab.
If you're anywhere near
Chicago, come by this year.
There's a website.
We've got symposia, we've got
a big birthday celebration.
We're going to have an
enormous open house.
Campus is open to the public.
Please come by.
And that's it.
Thank you.